Holly good morning
good morning while the ukrainians are
expected to launch that spring offensive
in the next few weeks and the fear is
that those leaked documents could hamper
them by revealing details about their
forces to Russia but spring has also
brought Holy Week celebrations here in
Ukraine and we marked it by visiting a
war-torn house of worship
the church in the village of lukashivka
is shattered and charred
it was used by Russian occupiers for
ammunition storage and shelled by
Ukraine's military as they pushed them
out
but the faithful still congregate here
beside the ruins praying for the safety
of their soldiers and for victory it
must have been an incredibly difficult
decision for the Ukrainian military to
bomb this church it says
father sir he told us we need to repair
everything Hearts Souls houses churches
it's been a long hard winter in Ukraine
Russian airstrikes targeted their
critical infrastructure knocking out
power and heating
but now spring is here and Vladimir
Putin's attempt to demoralize ukrainians
appears to have failed
he can't do it we're going to win these
women told us they all have husbands or
sons who are fighting
in Kiev Ukraine's military is working to
blunt Russia's deadly Invasion analyzing
the wreckage of these Russian drones to
help shoot down more of them these
so-called suicide drones made by Iran
are designed to detonate on impact these
are the drones that are being used to
kill ukrainians how do you feel looking
at them
they cause a lot of damage said this
officer who's hiding his identity for
security reasons but we do all we can to
defend our homes and our people Easter
time is when Christians celebrate the
resurrection of Jesus does that have
special meaning for ukrainians now that
you're in this war
Jesus was resurrected father sir he told
us and Ukraine will be to
most people here are Orthodox Christians
so they won't celebrate Easter until
next Sunday Ukraine's President Vladimir
zelenski has condemned Russia for
carrying out an attack on Palm Sunday
killing a man and his 11 year old
daughter Vlad
marveling at the resilience and the
faith of the Ukrainian people Holly
Williams in Ukraine for us thank you